CALLING I GREATLY APPRECIATE
IT. WHEN WAS THE FIRST TIME
YOU LAID EYES ON ZACK WILSON
COACH. I WAS A
DEFENSE COORDINATOR AT THE
UNIVERSITY OF UTAH SUMMER
CAMP AND HE WAS ABOUT 50
GRADE AND YOU KNOW,
I YOU CAN ALWAYS RECOGNIZE
THE GREAT ATHLETES EVEN WHEN
THEY'RE LITTLE AND HE KIND OF
JUST STOOD OUT THERE'S A
GROUP OF THEM THAT DID AND
JUST KIND OF FOLLOWED HIM AND
THEN YOU KNOW, WE WERE
ENOUGH WHEN I GOT THE HEAD
TO TO RECRUIT HIM AND REALLY
THANKFUL THAT HE WAS ABLE TO
COME HERE AND THROW THE ROCK
FOR US AND THEN OBVIOUSLY HAD
A GREAT SEASON LAST YEAR AND
THAT WAS PRETTY MUCH THE
FIRST TIME THAT HE'S BEEN
HUNTING PERCENT HEALTHY. AND
SO I THINK RIGHT NOW IS JUST
SCRATCHING THE SURFACE ON THE
THINGS THAT HE CAN DO ON THE
FOOTBALL FIELD. SO, YOU KNOW
WHEN YOU SAID FIFTH GRADE,
I'VE BEEN AROUND THE BLOCK A
FEW TIMES IN THE NFL AND
AROUND THE WORLD OF FOOTBALL.
I THOUGHT AM I MISSING JUST A
TYPE OF LIKE STAR RATING WHEN
YOU SO SO YOU'RE SAYING HE
WAS YOU'RE SAYING FIFTH GRADE
LIKE BETWEEN FOURTH AND SIXTH
GRADE LIKE LIKE LIKE THAT.
LIKE HE'S NINE YEARS OLD.
YEAH, YOU PRETTY MUCH WHEN
YOU FACE. I MEAN HE WAS I
THOUGHT HE WAS A GREAT
ATHLETE BACK TO END AND THEN
YOU JUST YOU YOU SEE THESE
KIDS. YOU KNOW, I REMEMBER
START LOOKS A LITTLE A WHEN
HE WAS A GREAT DEAL AYMAN
SAME SAME THING. YOU JUST SEE
THESE GUYS WHEN THEY'RE WHEN
THEY'RE OBVIOUSLY FURTHER
ALONG THAN DEFINITELY THERE'S
SOME GUYS THAT DEVELOP FASTER
AND THAN OTHERS, BUT YOU JUST
KIND OF NOTICED THE THINGS
THAT HE DID AS AN ATHLETE IS
JUST HIS FOOTBALL IQ AND THE
FACT THAT HE LOVED PLAYING
ON THE FIELD. THAT WAS THE
BEST PART OF HIS.
DAY WAS BEING OUT THERE
PLAYING FOOTBALL AND HE
PLAYED BOTH SIDES. IT WASN'T
JUST LIKE JUST OF QUARTERBACK
AND THAT WAS ALL BUT SURE
GUYS A GREAT ATHLETE. YOU CAN
DO A LOT OF DIFFERENT THINGS.
HE PLAYS POINT GUARD ON HIS
HIGH SCHOOL BASKETBALL TEAM.
SO HE'S GOT TONS OF
ATHLETICISM. HE CAN DUNK OUT
THE GYM AND AND YOU JUST KNEW
THAT THERE WAS SOMETHING
SPECIAL ABOUT HIM, BUT WHEN
YOU GET TO TALK TO HIM AND
GET TO MEET HIM IN PERSON AND
SIT AROUND AND YOU START TO
REALIZE THAT FOOTBALL IS WHAT
THIS GUY LOVES THE MOST
THAT'S HIS PASSION AND I
IMAGINE HE'S GOING TO MAKE A
LIVING OUT OF IT AND EVEN
HE'S DONE PLAYING HE'S GOING
TO I THINK HE'S GOING TO BE A
PHENOMENAL COACH IF THAT'S
WHAT HE WANTS TO GO INTO AND
HE'S GOT A GREAT CHARISMA. I
THINK HE'S GOT HE'S GOT HE'S
THAT THE TOTAL PACKAGE AND I
THINK YOU KNOW, I'M EXCITED
AS AN HONOR THAT I WAS ABLE
TO COACH HIM. WELL, I DO LOOK
FORWARD TO GETTING A CHANCE
TO CHAT WITH HIM BETWEEN NOW
AND THE DRAFT AND I JUST LOVE,
YOU KNOW STORIES OF JOURNEYS
AND THINGS OF THAT NATURE AND
SO WHEN YOU DID RECRUIT HIM
FOR BYU, DID YOU BASICALLY
SAY HELLO AGAIN AND SAY I SAW
YOU WHEN YOU WERE IN FIFTH
GRADE OR DID HE REMEMBER I
MEAN, WHAT WAS
THAT LIKE WHEN YOU FINALLY
GOT A CHANCE TO GET HIM
POTENTIALLY TO BYU WHEN YOU
WERE RECRUITING HIM. WELL,
YOU KNOW, HIS DAD WAS A
FORMER PLAYER AT UTAH AND YOU
JUST KIND OF YOU YOU ALWAYS
KNOW THE NAMES AND YOU SEE
YOU GUYS AT CAMPS EVERY YEAR.
YEAH AND DIFFERENT CAMPS AND
YOU SEE THEM, YOU KNOW AS
THEY GO THROUGHOUT FROM
MIDDLE SCHOOL TO HIGH SCHOOL
AND YOU KNOW, HE WAS ACTUALLY
COMMITTED TO BOISE EARLY AND
WE CAME IN LATE. I CAME IN
LATE RECRUITING AND AND LUCKY
US IT WAS
IT TOO LATE, YOU KNOW, AND HE
WAS ABLE TO
YELLS CHANGES COMMITMENT AND
COME TO BYU AND AND THE REST
IS HISTORY. AND I THE ONLY
UNFORTUNATE PART FOR ME IS
THAT I DON'T GET HIM BACK FOR
ANOTHER YEAR EXCITED FOR HIM
AND HE'S GOT HE'S GOT A GREAT
FUTURE AND I THINK I WAS
HOPING HE'D COME BACK. BUT
DEFINITELY THIS IS A GREAT
MOVE FOR HIM AND I'M EXCITED
FOR HIM AND HIS FAMILY AND
HIS HARD WORK AND SACRIFICE
TO START TO PAY OFF AND ONCE
YOU GET THE TO TALK TO HIM
AND JUST SIT DOWN TALK BALL,
YOU REALIZE EVERYTHING THAT
I'M TALKING ABOUT IN THIS
IT'S HARD TO SEE ON FILM BUT
YOU KNOW, HE JUST HAS THE
DROP SET IT OVER AND OVER AND
OVER AND OVER AGAIN TO SO
MANY DIFFERENT PEOPLE AND I
JUST HE BELONGS IN THAT
LEAGUE AND I'M EXCITED FOR
HIM AND WHATEVER TEAM OF
DRAFTS HIM. KALANI'S TOO
THE HEAD COACH AT BYU
FOOTBALL HERE ON THE RICH
EYES AND SHOW, YOU KNOW, I'M
FROM NEW YORK CITY SIR, AND I
KNOW JET FANS ARE
PARTICULARLY EXCITED WHEN
THEY SEE WHEN YOU SAY, YOU
KNOW FILM THERE'S BEEN A LOT
OF HIS FILM THAT HAS BEEN ON
SOCIAL MEDIA AND SHARED I CAN
GUARANTEE YOU BEING FROM NEW
YORK THAT MOST JET FANS HAVE
NOT SEEN A QUARTER LET ALONE
A FULL GAME OF BYU FOOTBALL
PRETTY MUCH.
TO BE VERY HONEST WITH YOU.
SO WHAT WOULD THEY BE GETTING
IN? ZACH WILSON? WHAT WOULD A
TEAM BE GETTING IN ZACH
WILSON? YOU TALKED ABOUT HIM
BEING A GAMER. WHAT HAS HE
BEEN LIKE IN TERMS OF
ADVERSITY FACING ADVERSITY
AND FACING THE HEAT THAT
YOU'VE SEEN COACH. THAT'S HIS
THAT'S HIS WHOLE THAT'S HIS
WHOLE GENERAL MAKEUP IN
FOOTBALL UNDER RECRUITED AND
HE SHOULD HAVE BEEN A
BIG-TIME RECRUIT AND DIDN'T
GET A LOT OF RECOGNITION KIND
OF A LATE BLOOMER, ESPECIALLY
IN THE IN HIS IN HIS HEIGHT
AND HIS GROWTH, BUT I THINK
HE
STARTED STARTED TO PUT
USED TOGETHER TOWARDS THE
SENIOR YEAR AND A LOT OF
TIMES RECRUITING TAKES PLACE
SO MUCH EARLIER THAN THAT AND
THEN AND THEN WHEN HE GOT
HERE HE CAME IN AS A TRUE
FRESHMAN COMPETED FOR A
STARTING SPOT IN EARNED THAT
SPOT MIDSEASON AND HE WASN'T
COMPLETELY ALL HEALTHY, BUT
THE GUY GRADUATED EARLY FROM
HIGH SCHOOL DIDN'T EVEN PLAY
BASKETBALL. HE SHE DECIDED TO
PUT THAT TO THE SIDE AND COME
HERE AND AND JOIN BYU IN THE
SPRING AND PLAY SPRING
FOOTBALL SO HE CAN COMPETE
FOR A STARTING SPOT. HE GOT
THE SPOT, YOU KNOW, HE
BATTLED LITTLE BIT INJURY THE
FRESHMAN SOPHOMORE YEAR AND
THIS IS MOSTLY JUST BECAUSE
THE GUY HAS BEEN SO ACTIVE IN
PLANE SO MANY DIFFERENT
SPORTS ONCE HE GOT TO THE
SURGEON SURGERIES AND GOT
TWO THINGS FIXED AND GOT
HEALTHY. YOU CAN SEE HIM JUST
TAKE OFF FROM THERE. AND THIS
WAS THE YOU KNOW, WE HAD A
WHEN HE DID GET HURT HE WE
HAD HAD A QUARTERBACK
CONTROVERSY AND HAD SOME HAD
A COMPETITION GOING ON AND HE
WAS ALL FOR THE GUY LOVES TO
COMPETE AND AND IF HE DOESN'T
GET THE SPOT, HE'S A GREAT
SUPPORT FOR THE TEAM.
GREAT TEAMMATE TO HAVE GREAT
LEADER AND YOU KNOW ONCE ONCE
A YEAR WAS ABLE TO GET THAT
SPOT BACK YOU SAW WHAT HE
COULD DO ON THE FIELD AND I
THINK YOU GET TO SEE THE
THINGS THAT HE DOES THAT I
THINK WORK. ETHIC IS THE KEY.
NOBODY IS AS CONFIDENT AS HE
IS GOING INTO A GAME BECAUSE
HE PUTS IN MORE TIME OFF THE
FIELD STUDIES TONS OF FILM.
HE WORKS LATE HOURS LIKE THE
COACHES DO HE LOVES WATCHING
FILM. HE WATCHES NFL FILM HE
WATCHES EVERYTHING AND COMES
UP WITH A LOT OF DIFFERENT
PLAYS. HE'S ALWAYS
RECOMMENDING
HE'S A HE'S A COACH'S DREAM
BUT ALSO A NIGHTMARE BECAUSE
HE LIKE HEY, HOW ABOUT THIS
PLAY? YOU KNOW, HOW ABOUT
THIS ONE? I LIKE THIS ONE AND
AND AND A LOT OF IT IS GREAT
IDEAS. AND THEN YOU HAVE TO
JUST KIND OF FIGURE OUT THAT
IT WORKS TOWARDS HIS HIS HIS
SKILL SET. AND SO THE SKY'S
THE LIMIT FOR THE GUY AND I
CAN'T WAIT TO SEE WHAT HE
DOES IN THE NFL WHEN IT'S
JUST FULL TIME THAT HE'S HAD
TO KIND OF BALANCE IT WITH
WITH SCHOOL HERE, YOU KNOW
AND SO HARD I COULD THEN BE
SCHOOL AT BYU IS AND NOW HE'S
JUST AWFUL TIME BALL, AND
I'VE TALKED TO HIM AND TEXT
HIM AND
THE GUY'S JUST DECIDED NOW
BECAUSE HE'S A FULL-TIME
FOOTBALL PLAYER. WELL, IT
SURE LOOKS LIKE HE'S JUST
SHOOTING UP DRAFT BOARDS
RIGHT NOW AND THAT THE
SITUATION WITH THE JETS WHAT
THEY'RE GOING TO DO WITH
ARNOLD AND WHAT MIGHT HAPPEN
WITH DESHAUN WATSON. I MEAN,
THERE'S A LOT OF DOMINOES AND
PLAY HERE THAT MIGHT WIND UP
WITH ZACH WILSON IN NEW YORK
OR WITH SOMEBODY ELSE SECOND
OVERALL WHEN YOU SAID THE NFL
FILM WATCHING WHAT ARE YOU
TALKING ABOUT? WHAT IS HE?
WHAT IS HE LOOKING WATER
COACH. HE WATCHES ALL KINDS
ON HIS OFF TIME. WELL GUYS
ARE PLAYING VIDEO GAMES AND
PLAYING THEIR PS FIVES AND
STUFF LIKE THAT. HE'S ON HIS
IPAD AND HIS SON HIS LAPTOP
WATCHING FILM. HE YOU CAN
TALK TO OUR VIDEO COORDINATOR.
HE DOWNLOADS NFL FILMS. SO
HE'S WATCHING PATRICK MAHOMES
AARON RODGERS ROETHLISBERGER.
HE'S WATCHING ALL THESE GUYS
AND I MEAN LIKE TONS OF FILM
AND THEN HE'LL TEXT ME AND
SAY HEY, I LIKE THIS PLAY.
WHAT DO YOU THINK AND THERE'S
LIKE, YEAH, MAN, WHATEVER YOU
LIKE. LET'S JUST TAKE A LOOK
AT IT. AND YOU KNOW, HE JUST
LOVES FOOTBALL AND THAT'S
WHAT HE'S ABOUT. AND AND I
THINK HE'S IN THE RIGHT
SETTING NOW AND IT MAKES A
LOT OF SENSE WHY HE'S
SKYROCKETING BECAUSE PEOPLE
ARE ACTUALLY TALKING TO HIM.
IT'S NOT LIKE THIS IS JUST
HAPPENING OUT OF NOTHING
PEOPLE THAT KNOW WHAT THEY'RE
TALKING ABOUT IN FOOTBALL ARE
SITTING DOWN AND TALKING BALL
WITH HIM AND THEY'RE COMING
AWAY IMPRESSED. AND THAT'S
JUST TALKING TO HIM IN
PERSON WHEN THEY SEE HIM
THROW. I THINK HE'S GONNA
HE'S GONNA BACK IT ALL UP,
BUT I CAN TELL YOU ONE THING
BECAUSE HE LOVES FOOTBALL.
HE'S SUCH A GREAT SUPPORT.
IN THE TEAM IN THE POSITION
ROOM, YOU'LL FIGURE IT OUT. I
MEAN, HE WASN'T THE STARTED
RIGHT AWAY AS A TRUE FRESHMAN.
HE SAT THERE SUPPORTED HIS
TEAMMATES AND THEN WHEN IT
WAS TIME FOR HIM TO TAKE THE
TO TAKE THE REINS MIDWAY
THROUGH THE SEASON HE WAS
ABLE TO FLY WITH IT. AND
THAT'S JUST HOW HE WORKS AND
THEN WHEN WE DISRUPTED IT
BECAUSE OF INJURY AND WE SAID
HEY WE HAVE TO OPEN UP THE
QUARTERBACK COMPETITION. HE
DIDN'T HE DIDN'T FEEL
ENTITLED FOR ANYTHING. HE
SAID LET'S GO TO WORK MAN.
LET'S DO IT AND IT WAS PRETTY
EVIDENT RIGHT AWAY THAT HE
WAS UP FOR THE COMPETITION.
GUY THAT'S GOING TO WORK HARD
GET ALONG WITH ALL HIS
TEAMMATES NOT THINK NOT FEEL
ENTITLED TO ANYTHING. THEN
YOU'RE GOING TO GET THE RIGHT
RIGHT GUY AND THE WEATHER'S
SUGGESTS OR WHOEVER DRAFTS
HIM. I THINK THEY'RE GOING TO
GET A GREAT PLAYER. DO YOU
HAVE A GOOD EXAMPLE COACH TO
TALKE OF HIM SAYING LET'S TRY
THIS PLAY AND THEN YOU'RE
LIKE, OH I COULD TAKE A LOOK
AT IT. AND THEN IT ACTUALLY
HAPPENED IN A GAME AND IT
RESULTED IN ONE SOMETHING ONE
COMES TO MIND IS IT'S THE
HOUSTON IS A HOUSTON
SCREENPLAY THAT WE FLIPPED
THE BALL LIKE UNDERHAND
FLIPPED IT
IN THE RED ZONE.
AGAINST HOUSTON AND HE GOT
THAT FROM PATRICK MAHOMES
THAT IT THEN WE I MEAN WE
CALLED IT THE CHIEFS PLAY,
YOU KNOW, SO THAT'S ONE PLACE
AND IF YOU CAN IT'S DOCUMENT
YOU CAN KIND OF LOOK IT UP
AND SEE WHAT HE DOES. BUT
THERE'S A LOT OF THOSE PLAYS
THAT HE'S JUST REALLY LIKES
AND YOU KNOW FOOTBALL,
THERE'S LIKE NOBODY HAS A
STAMP ON EVERYTHING. NOBODY
HAS A MONOPOLY ON ALL THE
PLAYS. SO WHEN YOU HAVE A GUY
THAT JUST LOVES FOOTBALL AND
ALL THESE PLAYS IN AND HE
SEES WHAT HE CAN WORK ON BUT
BUT HE DOES ALL THESE
DIFFERENT THROWS. HE'S A BIG
FAN OF ALL THE QUARTERBACKS.
I MEAN, I THINK A BIG PART OF
HIS EXCITEMENT GOING TO THE
NFL'S THAT HE GETS TO SEE
THESE QUARTERBACKS AFTER THE
GAME AND KIND OF CONNECT WITH
HIM AND TALK TO HIM THAT HE
JUST LIKES THAT HE IF YOU
WERE IF YOU'LL ALLOW HIM THE
TIME TO DO IT HE WOULD JUST
SIT THERE AND PICK THE BRAIN
OF ALL THE GREAT QUARTERBACKS.
WE HAVE STEVE YOUNG AND
OTHER ALUMNI THAT HAVE PLAYED
HERE BYU THAT KEEP IN TOUCH
WITH HIM AND HE'S ALWAYS
TALKING BALL WITH THOSE GUYS.
JOHN BECK IS
HIS TRAINER SO SURE AND YOU
KNOW MYSELF AND OUR OFFICE
COORDINATOR, HE'S ALWAYS
STAYING IN TOUCH WITH ALL
THESE GUYS AND THEN IT'S ALL
BALL MAN. THE GUY LOVES BALL
AND AND THAT'S WHAT HE WANTS
TO TALK ABOUT. THAT'S WHAT HE
WANTS TO LIVE AND LIVE WITH
AND THEN AND NOW HE'S IN IT.
SO HIS VACATION WOULD BE
PROBABLY GO TO SOMEWHERE
SUNNY SIT ON THE BEACH AND
WATCH FOOTBALL FILM. KALANI
SAID 'TAKE BYU HEAD FOOTBALL
COACH HERE ON THE RICH EISEN
SHOW. LET'S TALK ABOUT YOU
AND YOUR PROGRAM JUST A
LITTLE BIT HERE IF YOU DON'T
MIND, SO IT'S COVID-19
YOUR
YOUR SCHEDULE GETS TOTALLY
EXPLODED BECAUSE SO MANY OF
THE TEAMS THAT YOU MIGHT BE
PLAYING AGAINST SAY WE'RE
JUST GOING TO ONLY STICK IN
OUR CONFERENCE YOU HAVE IF
I'M NOT MISTAKEN. JUST THREE
GAMES LEFT. YOU COBBLE
A SCHEDULE YOU GO 11 IN
ONE YOU DEVELOP A
QUARTERBACK THAT MAYBE THE
SECOND OVERALL PICK IN THE
DRAFT AND YET THERE'S STILL
SO MUCH CONVERSATION ABOUT
POWER FIVE CONFERENCE IS IF
YOU WILL TAKE IN THEIR BALL
AND CREATING THEIR OWN WORLD.
DO YOU SAY ABOUT THAT
COACH
HEY, WHAT DO WE GOT TO PLAY
FOOTBALL? AND THEN SO I DON'T
KNOW THE ALL THE POLITICS AND
EVERYTHING INVOLVED IN IT. I
HAVE A GROUP OF GUYS THAT
LOVE THE GAME OF FOOTBALL AND
THEY'RE VERY APPRECIATIVE OF
THE OF ALL THE PEOPLE THAT
MADE IT HAPPEN LAST YEAR. AND
SO WE'RE JUST GOING TO KEEP
PLAYING THIS GAME JUST FULL
OF GRATITUDE AND APPRECIATION
FOR THOSE THAT MAKE IT HAPPEN
AND AND AND YOU KNOW, WE'RE
REALLY THANKFUL FOR THE TEAMS
THAT STEP UP AND WANT TO PLAY
US AND WE HAVE A SCHEDULE NOW
AND 2021 THAT WE'RE EXCITED
AND WE'VE BEEN IN THE IN
SITUATIONS WHERE WE PLAY.
I'M REALLY TOUGH GAMES
AGAINST P5 TEAMS, BUT IT WAS
WE'RE ALLOWED TO SEE IT
ALLOWED US TO SEE WHERE WE
CAN DO IT AND HOW WE CAN
IMPROVE AND GET BETTER DEPTH
WISE, BUT I'M NOT GOING TO
GET INTO ALL THE YOU KNOW, WE
DESERVE THIS TYPE OF STUFF. I
JUST KNOW THAT THESE GUYS
LOVE FOOTBALL THEY WANT TO
PLAY AND THEY APPRECIATE THE
FACT THAT THE OTHERS ARE
MAKING IT HAPPEN FOR THEM. SO
THE CONVERSATIONS THAT YOU'RE
ASKING PROBABLY IS MORE FOR
THE ARE A D AND OUR
ADMINISTRATION, BUT I'LL LET
THEM HANDLE IN THE MEANTIME.
I'M ENJOYING JUST COACHING
GUYS AT LOVE BALL. I LOVE
THAT. THAT'S GREAT. THAT'S ED.
YEAH, I DO. I'M FASCINATED
BECAUSE I WAS SITTING HERE IN
THIS CHAIR WATCHING THE
SEASON UNFOLD DO YOU THINK
ANY TEAMS DUCT YOU THIS YEAR
GIVEN THE OPPORTUNITY YOU'RE
LIKE, HEY, WILL YOU LOVE
BALL? LET'S PLAY BALL AND
THEN TEAMS WERE SAYING WE
NEED SOMEONE TO PLAY AND YOU
RAISE YOUR HAND AND MAYBE
THEY DIDN'T WANT ANY PC. YOU
THINK THAT HAPPENED THIS YEAR
COACH. NO. LISTEN II I GET TO
KNOW A LOT OF THESE COACHES
IN SO MANY DIFFERENT
CONFERENCES AND DIFFERENT
SCHOOLS AND THEY'RE ALL YOU
DON'T COACH FOOTBALL.
YOU'RE GOING TO DUCK AWAY
FROM COMPETITION. SO NONE OF
THEM WANT TO DO THAT. THE
PROBLEM IS THAT YOU HAVE TO
WORK THROUGH ALL THESE
DIFFERENT, YOU KNOW, THE
CONFERENCE'S MAKE THESE
STATEMENTS AND THEY MAKE
THESE RESTRICTIONS. SO THESE
TEAMS CAN'T PLAY BUT IF
YOU'RE ALLOWED JUST TWO
COACHES TO MAKE THE DECISION,
I GUARANTEE YOU EVERYBODY
WOULD PLAY MORE FOOTBALL AND
THEY WOULD ALLOW IT TO HAPPEN.
SO NEVER EVER DO I THINK THAT
A TEAM WOULD EVER DUCK US
BECAUSE THEY DON'T I MEAN,
THAT'S JUST WHEN YOUR
COMPETITOR YOU WANT TO PLAY
THE BEST. IT DOESN'T MATTER
WHO IT IS AND I'VE MET ALL
THESE COACHES AND ALL THESE
THE FIELD I MEAN, LET ME JUST
GIVE YOU EXAMPLE WE HAVE GUYS
THAT TRAIN ALL YEAR ROUND FOR
LITERALLY, MAYBE TWO MINUTES
OF STRAIGHT FOOTBALL THAT
THEY GET TO PLAY THE WHOLE
ENTIRE SEASON AND AND THEN WE
GET TO PLAY AGAINST PEOPLE
THAT MAKE THAT SACRIFICE. AND
SO WHEN YOU HAVE PEOPLE THAT
ARE VERY SIMILAR IN THE WAY
THAT THEY THINK THEY'RE ALL
COMPETITORS ALL THE COACHES
OUT THERE LIKE TO COMPETE ALL
THE PLAYERS LIKE TO COMPETE.
IT'S JUST ALL THE
RESTRICTIONS OF THE
CONFERENCES OR SCHOOLS ME
PUT THEM IN INTO BUT NEVER
WHO WOULD EVER THINK THAT A
COACH OR A PLAYER OR TEAM HAS
EVER DUCKING ANYONE ALRIGHT,
AND THEN I DO WANT TO GIVE
YOU THIS OPPORTUNITY BEFORE I
SEND YOU BACK INTO YOUR
MONDAY IS I'M CLEARLY CALLING
UP ABOUT ZACH WILSON. I'M
FASCINATED BY HIM AND HIS
RISE
ASCENSION AND WHAT A
CRUCIAL PLAYER HE'S GOING TO
BE IN THIS UPCOMING NFL DRAFT.
I'M SURE YOU HAVE SOME
OTHERS THAT ARE AVAILABLE.
YOU WANT TO POUND THE TABLE
FOR THEM LITTLE BIT BEFORE I
LET YOU GO TODAY. WE GOT A
LOT OF WE HAVE A LOT OF GREAT
PLAYERS. I MEAN WE HAVE THREE
GUYS THAT ARE COMING OUT.
LEAVE, YOU KNOW FOR THE NFL
DRAFT OF THE DECLARED EARLY
AND YOU KNOW - MILLS OUR
RECEIVER THAT YOU SAW ZACH
THROW INTO A LOT AND BRADY
CHRISTIANS ARE LEFT TACKLE
BELOW. ALL THREE OF THOSE
GUYS CAME OUT OF HERE EARLY
AND AND AND I'M HAPPY FOR
THEM IN THEIR OPPORTUNITIES.
WE HAVE A LOT OF GREAT
PLAYERS THAT ARE ON THE VERGE
OF GETTING DRAFTED AND A LOT
OF GREAT OLD LINEMAN AND I
THINK WE'RE GOING TO THIS IS
GOOD BE A GOOD START FOR US
PUDDLING PEOPLE INTO THE NFL
AND THEY THE NFL NEEDS A LOT
PEOPLE INTO THE NFL AND THEY
THE NFL NEEDS A LOT OF GUYS
FROM BYU THERE.
IT'S BEEN REALLY GOOD IN THE
PAST AND THAT'S AND HOPEFULLY
WE CAN KEEP THIS TRAIN
ROLLING AND USE YOUR WHEN YOU
WERE WHEN YOU WERE IN THE NFL
FOR THAT ONE YEAR COACH
BEFORE YOU GOT HURT DICK
LEBEAU. WAS HE YOUR FIRST
HEAD COACH IN THE NFL WAS YOU
THINK EITHER? YEAH THE
BANGLES. YEAH, AND THEN I
MEAN IT WAS IT DIDN'T EVEN
GET REALLY STARTED RIGHT, BUT
JUST LOVE THE FACT THAT
FOOTBALL. IT'S INEVITABLE.
UNLESS YOU'RE TOM BRADY THAT
FOOTBALL WILL PROBABLY END.
AND THERE'S AND YOU WON'T
LIKE THE TIMING OF IT ALL YOU
KNOW, AND THAT'S JUST THE
REST OF US. NOT ON NOT
EVERYBODY CAN HAVE THE TOM
BRADY EFFECT. BUT AND WHEN IT
DID END FOR ME, I JUST NEEDED
TO BE AROUND IT AND THEN AND
LUCKILY IT TURNED ME TO
COACHING AND SO I'VE BEEN I'M
JUST REALLY HONORED TO BE IN
THE FOOTBALL LIFE AND TO BE
DOING THIS FOR A LIVING AND
BEING CONNECTED WITH SO MANY
GREAT PEOPLE COACH REALLY
APPRECIATE THE TIME. THANK
YOU FOR THE INSIGHT CONGRATS
ON THE GREAT SEASON AND BEST
OF LUCK MOVING ON LET'S LET'S
CHAT AGAIN.
APPRECIATE IT. APPRECIATE IT.
RICH. THANK YOU YOU BET. THAT
IS COACH KALANI'S TATAKI OF
BYU FOOTBALL.